Long story short, the plane went down. The Chinese pilot died.
Uh the name of this pilot, Chinese pilot who crashed into us
was named Wong. >> No, I what can you Okay, so now so now
we'll just get to the question I actually asked you which was
point to the issue where Trump is better than Hassan outside
of like military or like economic issues where you would defer
to like an expert in your cabinet. We like you said we we don't
know but I mean both acknowledge >> that I think Trump
is far more of a psychopath far more of a hateful person far
more of a bad person in general I think Hassan actually has some
moral character to him is >> holy never just watch the
video I'm out why can't I get through a sentence >> never
mind >> watch the video talk to you later bye >> there
would
okay actually do he said watch a bit of
>> this is uh Hassan. I assume this is some very far-lefty
person that he's going to skinwalk a little bit. Let's check
it >> Oh, the US military is planning for a war with China.
Oh sh
Oh, here we go >> This is where it really comes out. Okay,
Hassan's opinions on Taiwan, what he thinks about Taiwan is like
the real If you want to know what he believes, this is like the
perfect place to do it. >> dude. You know, you know, listen,
expect Johnny Harris had to do one good video so he could do
like 10 ones where he's like, "Let's invade." >> Here's
why. Here's why Taiwan needs to be defended with military force
and perhaps nuclear weapons. You know what I >> Taiwan
is part of China. No,
>> Taiwan number one. >> You got to expect that like
the top of the hour adre. You know what I mean? In Brazil, socialist
people call North Korea as popular Korea or people's Korea. I
don't know the real translate. Sorry. Haha. >> That's awesome.
>> Yeah, I love that. I'm going to start calling it popular
Korea. >> Yeah, it's actually not that bad of a video.
Well, you know, you know what's not that bad of >> uh evil
Johnny Bravo. I I just sometimes um if I haven't like planned
out my So, you'll tell you can tell sometimes I've like planned
things out to go in a very specific order and then when I haven't
I'm just like, you know, I don't I don't just waiting to catch
a vibe. Okay. Kind of wine and catch a vibe. of a video, the
top of the hour ad break as long as you're subscribed because
in that case, you don't see those ads and you get to avoid them.
Uh, the way to avoid them is either with a five boom. >> Come
on, >> man. Thank you for the subs. Brazil mentioned. Hell
yeah, dude. Um, >> majority of people watch our North Korea
video. We're Brazilian. Like all the top comments are from Brazil.
I don't know what the what the whole North Korea Brazil solidarity
thing is, but guys love each other. >> Oh no. >> Uhoh.
Uh oh. Dude, dude, delete this. Delete this. Delete this. Delete
this. Is this CIA? CIA beanie. Are they the same person? CIA.
Dude, delete this. Delete this. I wore it one time. >> Okay,
I will say time stamp could have used some refinement here, Supreme.
Just >> Little little refinement on the time stamp wouldn't
have killed us, >> guys. No, >> just saying. >> Shut
up. Stop it. Um,
all right. Let's Should we Holy news coverage, but dude, we've
gone to so many different directions. Holy. Okay. >> Holy
cow. >> Holy cam.
Dude, my ADHD is out of control today. How the did I driver comment
on tips? >> Like 45 minutes to an hour of this is worth
watching.
mom get shocking earful from >> I'm I'm just going to say
this guy is like a far leftist right like a super far like a
like an actual tanky would be this guy actual tanky I'm assuming
just because if Hassan's going to express like tanky opinions
I'm assuming he has to be like a tanky this guy right otherwise
Hassan would not just be expressing these things right I'd say
Hassan's ideology is roughly equivalent with like what's in his
background and he does have some tanky things but he's also got
a lot of video game stuff he's got some anime stuff right This
is like who he is is what's in his background. >> He's
a delivery driver. France brothers. Why is Paris always
burning? >> I didn't abandon Collins. We have >> All right.
You know what? Let's do the Johnny Harris one cuz I I also want
to >> No, we can do Collins while we do this. But we don't
have uh we don't have anybody calling in. So, it's all good.
>> Watch this. The $100 Disney food challenge in Paris.
Most expensive food in Europe. >> I don't think he's a
tanky. I think he's a campus communist. He wants the Soviets
to come back and win the Cold War. Okay. Camp. I should know
some of these terms more. Uh, Breaking House. Freedom Caucus
just expelled Marjorie Taylor Green apparently for not being
farright or MAGA enough. Finally, someone's coming after her
for being fake and a phony. I agree. Uh, all right. Let's do
this one. Let's start with this.
>> There's a small volcanic island of >> Yeah, he's
so good at editing. I always You always got to hand it to him.
Okay. >> Nobody lives here, but here's footage from January
2023 of >> They're the descendants of losers. Now they're
just Oh, wait. So you can be like genetically a loser. Is that
true? You just be genetically a loser. I feel like that flies
in the face of like lefty ideology in so many ways, Vain. But
maybe not. Maybe you believe people can be genetic losers. I
have some other candidates for you if you want to go through
those. I'll Can I just throw them at you and you can tell me
who the genetic losers are? >> No. No, that's not. Maybe.
>> No. Arriving to island. >> Their task is to build
a couple of >> He's talking about the Taiwanese. I know
who he's talking about. runways on the island and some storage
facilities for ammunition. The Japanese government has been paying
local fishermen to stay away from this island. That's because
they're turning it into a military base. The island is being
built by Japan, but one of its main purposes, >> which
is very cool and good. I sure hope China's not doing that cuz
if they are doing that, then that's not cool and not good. Not
good. nor good or nor >> has to do with the United States.
American fighter jets and aircraft carriers have had to do their
drills and practices down here on this island, but now station
at this island, moving them much closer to this ocean and to
one country in particular,
>> Mashima is just one of many islands that are being >> the
island chain >> loaded up with military hardware, most
of it coming from the United States. It's part of this chain
of militarized islands, an effort of defense,
aggression, depending on how you look at it. It's a line that
centers on Taiwan. And it's what one official was referring to
when they said that 2023 is likely to >> By the way, Janet
Yellen is currently in China today talking to them about god
knows what. and as the most transformative year in US force posture
in this region in a generation. This line is a symbol of the
rising tensions between global superpowers. And I want to show
you why this is happening now and what it means for the future
of this >> This is unlike anything >> we we haven't
gotten to any actual statement. He's like uh he's obviously pro
in the in the ceno US war. Okay. He's obviously like pro-China.
He obviously has a lot of sympathies for China. It's it's obvious
just in his like in his like throwaway commentary, right? Like
I don't think anybody's confused about how Hassan likes China.
A lot of we'll have to go a little deeper than that to probably
sus out exactly what he believes or what he like ideologically
commits to. >> US Navy has done since World War II. >> Tensions
are rising in one of the most hotly contested regions on the
planet, the South China Sea.
>> why? Why? Why is it one of the most hotly contested
places on the planet? a question we must ask ourselves. Like
I'm sorry I always have to ask why is America there? Like no,
I know that we we we have this attitude where like of course
we have to be there to preserve freedom, right? But it's like
but why are we there really? What what's up with >> Doesn't
make any sense.
>> Hey, um going to pause the story really quick to tell
you about
>> Back into this important story. >> Here we go.
>> There would be tension without the US though. No, there
what? No. Wait, there absolutely would be. Does Assan think that
China's navy is like uh capable of like really with Japan's navy?
Uh that might that's getting way closer now. But for a very long
time, Japan's navy is like kind of outclassed. That's why Japan's
doing like a naval buildup, right? But Japan's technology is
like I believe decades ahead of China's even still. Japan doesn't
have a navy. What? How? What?
>> Oh, the Fed joined. >> Japan doesn't have a navy.
Can we think of some other reasons that there might be tension
in the South China Sea >> then the US? Uh probably the
fact that Taiwan is like to China's thinking like a rogue state
that is supposed to be like that occupies their territory and
they want to reintegrate it. >> Have you heard about the
fact that like the PLA Navy the plan the Chinese navy are like
huge to everybody? They're like >> Yeah. They that they
like run over Filipino fishermen all the time. Yeah, I've heard
of that. >> Yeah, the Philippines. >> The Filipino
fishermen are not having a good time in this. South China Sea.
>> So if there's tension in the South China Sea, it's because
China is trying to swing its ground and make the South China
Sea its territory. It's like sovereign territory.
>> I believe they say like they b what is it that they
drew a map and then they did like a dashed line and now China's
like that's we own everything in that dash line or something.
>> Yeah. Is that Johnny Harris like explains it in this
video. I just can't remember. I watched the video when it came
out. I just don't remember. There's quite a bit of history here.
It's like it's down to the level where they literally changed
their vocabulary for. You know how we changed uh the Gulf of
Mexico to the Gulf of America? The Chinese uh they >> they
previously uh referred to this as the South what was it? Nanzonguhai
South China Sea. Now they've changed their vocabulary to Jungo
Nanghai which means the China South Sea right. It seems probably
not that significant on its face but um
>> so I don't know if you heard about this but in summer
2001 something really crazy happened. Have you heard about >> No.
You never heard that something really crazy happened in summer
of 2001. >> Um, oh no, summer of 2001. >> That'll
be 911. No, >> no, not 911. Actually, three months before
911. >> September 2001. What are you talking >> I'm
making a I'm making a yoke. Okay. A couple months before 911.
>> Oh, September 21st. >> US spy plane in like I
think May or June 2001, a US spy plane crash landed on a Chinese
island called Hainan. And uh it was bad news. It was bad news.
It was really crazy. It's like a somehow lost to history, but
it's a incredible >> snafu before. I think I think you've
explained this to me before that. >> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Keep going. >> Long story short, there was a difference
between how the US and the China uh interpreted the UN maritime
charter and um basically everybody sided with the US and uh basically
that like intern I'm sorry that territorial waters up to about
11 I think either miles or nautical miles, one or the other,
I can't remember. Uh, and then from 11 to 200 miles, it's what's
called an economic exclusion zone, which is where basically the
host country's military can patrol it to make sure that people
are following international law, but that uh like has to remain
open and free for everybody to traverse. And so we were flying
our spy planes through that EEZ, and they scrambled a jet to
come up and meet our spy plane basically. And um we this had
happened a lot. We knew the pilot, his name literally, well,
we'll get to his name in a minute, but this happened a lot. They
scrambled these jets, Chinese J8, J82 I think. Um,
and this guy was like really aggressive. We knew the pilot. He
had he'd like been sent to interceptor spy planes before and
he flew a little too close and literally crashed into the plane
and like caused some of the like cabling to wrap around the ailerons.
Long story short, the plane went down. The Chinese pilot died.
Uh, the name of this pilot, Chinese pilot who crashed into us
was named Wong. And our some of our >> everybody assumed
this was a joke. >> It's literally his name. I'm not even
kidding. You can look it up. Uh anyway, so our servicemen, some
of our servicemen from a spy plane uh spent I think like 13 days
about 2 weeks in captivity in China. Can you imagine? Can you
imagine? Most people have not heard of this. And uh so basically
from that because everyone sort of like recognized uh the United
States interpretation of the maritime charter that you know whatever
we were in the EEZ, it was wrong for you to crash into us. Now,
the way that we solved this was we both we did we did like the
foreign policy. We did the diplomacy that we normally do with
China, which is we're like, we're very sorry that this happened.
You know, it's very similar to the way we're like, we acknowledge
that you say that there's one China. Um, so the Chinese response
to this, basically, the legacy of this is China was like, okay,
we can only control up to 11 miles off the shore or whatever.
That's that's as far as our international waters go. Okay, we're
going to build a bunch of islands 22 mi apart. And so, that's
basically what they've been doing. They've been building ATLs
in the South China Sea that are about like 20 mi apart so they
can extend their international waters to like basically claim
the South China >> Okay. Is no other country doing that
in response? Wouldn't the Philippines be able to do that like
basically in >> Uh no. I don't I don't think as prolifically
not nearly as prolifically. I don't think anybody is claiming
trying to like snatch up territory in the South China Sea other
than China. Uh this just goes to show like this is there's tension
in the South China Sea because China is literally trying to expand
into >> Okay. Okay. Like through force. >> So they
are generating the actual tension. Okay. Yes. And the probably
a lot of people would be upset about that even if they like even
if the US wasn't there, they'd still be complaining about it.
They might not be, you know, they might not feel as confident
opposing China, but they would still be complaining about it.
They'd still be >> Uh yeah. Yeah. So basically all the
all of China's neighboring countries, uh the Philippines, you
know, had this guy named Duterte. I don't know if you remember
this guy. >> Uh he was like, >> he was a big America
guy and he was a big China. >> We talked about him recently.
Yeah. Yeah, because people have been acting a fool over there,
I remember. And um he was like a big China s and he went to Beijing
and like sat in lobbies trying to curry favor with Xiinping for
years and years basically for his entire presidency like wanting
to start military cooperation and he was [__] ignored
uh because China just like hates all their neighbors. They're
super [__] racist in China. They're they they are
so ethnosremacist. I I don't understand why Hassan has no problem
with this. He probably just doesn't acknowledge it honestly.
But um yeah, so basically Duter got voted out and uh after he
kicked out the US Navy and Bong Bong Marcos had to uh basically
say, "Please come back, US Navy. Please, China's like horrible
to us. They're they spray us with these giant water cannons,
you know, they like go into our places where we've been fishing
for years and they just like they hose us out." And that's true.
And we did. So we we uh I think Biden Yeah. reannounced like
basically new agreements with the >> Just to give you guys
some background on what happens in South China Sea. I feel like
there's a what do you call it? There's like a little bit there
that in my opinion the US were probably dying to get back in
and were perfectly h I feel like you say Bongo Marcos went back
to them by the way I love his name but um went back to them was
like you have to come back. I feel like the US was like for the
love of God we got to get somebody in there who let us back in
because this is I think right they they really they do want to
contain China there right? Yeah,
>> there's a huge portion of this that all comes down to
the fact that the South China Sea is so shallow that you can't
get like submarines out of there without them being tracked.
And then once you've tracked them before they do their descent,
like you uh you could just track them basically like maintaining
some control or being able to scan the South China Sea, I think
is pretty important to making sure China doesn't have like an
effective nuclear triad,
>> Yeah, that's exactly right. Yes. >> Yeah. So
>> we are competing for them. Yeah. >> Well, yeah.
Among But but I mean like that's kind of justified because look
what happens when China is bigger and stronger than its neighbors.
They they bully their neighbors. They have tons of border tensions.
They have skirmishes with India constantly. >> Yeah, I
could see that. I know Japan that's like I think why Japan aligns
so closely with the US. Like even now like I think they're basically
like yeah we like everybody. Also I think Japan's basically always
been like for the love of God just let us spend to our NATO budget.
like let us spend on the military. God, these Chinese people
they've been able to for I think 5 >> No, they've been
they've been going hard on on expanding their navy and they have
like naval technology.
They didn't they did it's surprising how they're very much similar
to World War II. I believe they don't have like a ton of stuff,
but I think their subs are basically like the second like after
the US in terms of the actual technology, how stealth they are,
how like effective they are in combat, how how like good they
are in general. Um, I believe they're second to the US, I believe,
but I'm not 100% >> All right, we could chat shop all day,
but we should probably get back to the video. I just wanted to
give you guys some background on what happens in the South China
Sea. >> Yeah, sure. Thank you. Um, I might pull this other
guy in. I think this guy wants to come argue about the Hassan
versus Wait, hold on. If you had to pick Hassan versus Trump,
who you picking today? Like today, you're put could put somebody
in office today. If you could swap Trump out with Hassan, who
would you do it right now? Ex everything else >> Everything
else equal. Okay. So the problem with this is like this hypothetical
like I don't know it kind of relies on on a lot of conditions
that have to be answered first. Are we saying that Hassan gets
to >> I can totally agree with that. If you ask those conditions
first if you just start arguing one of the sides I'm going to
I'm going to assume you you will just take like what I have been
saying is the the hypothetical right you want to say oh I need
all these questions answered first then we can talk about that.
But with Connor and and uh Pisco, the whole point is like right
now today, who is closer to me? Who is like my better ally? Charlie
Kirk or Hassan? Like who who is more on my side? And that's like
not even a question. It's just obviously Hassan, right? He obviously
agrees with way more of the policies than you think you would
have. >> No, I I'm not I'm not so quick to agree to that.
Um I think it's much closer than you than you might expect. And
here's why. Because Hassan would be the commanderin-chief of
the military and if there's one thing he's spoken about with
this one, this is the one thing I gave away too was he would
probably recall all military like he would probably just he would
abandon like all all posts. So
hold on. >> Think about the repercussions of that. It would
mean a nuclear Iran in the near future. Uh, can you imagine if
Hassan was in charge of the US military
and like do >> you think Iran was close to a nuclear weapon
right now or do you just think if Assan was the leader of the
US that Iran would immediately like go balls to the wall and
building a nuclear weapon? From what I understand the US intelligence
like uh actual reports said no no they're not close to building
a nuke. >> They would be far less inhibited. Their timeline
would be greatly accelerated if they if they had to spend less
of their resources fighting proxy wars with the United States.
It would mean uh Chinese expansion. It would mean pro very likely
a Chinese nuclear triad. It would it would mean probably well
honest to God it's such a gift that Ukraine has given Russia
so much trouble because you know can you imagine if it was before
Ukraine it would I don't think Assan would have sent aid to Ukraine.
I don't know to >> Go ahead. >> Do you think the
commander-in-chief is really capable of that? I I just I wonder
sometimes because I know Trump basically said the Ukraine policy
the Ukraine policy they've gone with is almost the exact opposite
of what he advocated for, right? like openly and then suddenly
out of nowhere he was like actually Putin sucks and I'm gonna
support Ukraine and I'm going to send Ukraine more weapons. So
I don't know >> who can say who can say why that is because
listen at the end of the day I think Donald Trump actually cares
about the survival of of America the country like sure he's the
drain the swamp guy but I don't think Hassan has that much dedication
to America as the global hedgeimon at all. I think he thinks
America having hedgeimonyy is bad and I think he would do a lot
to um to sabotage our hedge money and I don't think he understands
what the knock on effects of that would be. >> Sure. But
I'm saying that probably he's equipped to understand those in
a way that's similar to Trump and it seems like Trump even though
he is totally against those things even though he has been like
essentially pro Putin right he gets into office he has to make
decisions those decisions don't go anywhere near the way he's
described them going when he is out of office. Yeah, I think
that's true. But I think that's because somebody can sit down
with Trump and be like, "Listen, Trump, this is why this is actually
pretty bad for America. Uh, we want to be number one. We want
to be world leaders, right?" And I think Trump would answer that
and be like, "Yes." And and be honest. We don't I don't know.
It's like hard to argue. It's tough to say what goes on in Trump's
head. >> So that's Well, that's if you were to say that
to Hassan. >> So you think if you think if you sat Hassan
down with here's like the intelligence, they're going to invade
Taiwan. They're going to basically like involve these people.
We have to maintain this control here. Here's the reasons we
have to maintain it. You think Assan would get all of that explained
to him and go yes I think America like in even if he is confronted
with the reality like I can actually see the facts now I have
all the intelligence you think you think Hassan is a worse decision
maker than Trump I mean he said in that uh leftovers show that
he thinks Taiwan should go back to China that he was like oh
yeah they're like so ethnically uh and like racially similar
they have the same language it would be really easy they should
just do it or something. >> Sure. And I'm saying that if
he was prevy to the information that the US government would
be, right, that I think we both have a good idea that the US
government would be and he would know what would happen to the
people in Taiwan if they did reintegrate, right? Do you think
he would still be totally down with that? >> Yeah. Yeah.
I think he would. >> I think I think it's from a place
of ignorance of like what China would be doing there if they
regain if they were able to invade. I think it's a from a place
of ignorance that he has these beliefs. I think he is broadly
not an evil person and this would require like a level of evil
that he has shown no capacity for at all. >> Okay. He only
acts from a place of ignorance. He does not act from a place
of evil. >> Consider this. He would have to go out in front
of all the people that love and support him and all the people
that voted him in and say, "Ladies and gentlemen, I would just
like to tell you that, you know, I used to think that China having
Taiwan was pretty cool, but you know what? The State Department
has shown me some secret intelligence and uh and you know what?
I trust them. I now believe in the most absurd way you possibly
could, right? But it would be something like, I was unaware of
certain parts of the situation. I have now gotten all the information
that can >> just that part. Can you really imagine him
saying I was unaware of I guys? I didn't really know a lot about
about that about that region of the world. >> He could
he did the exact way Trump would, right? There are some very
smart people who are in charge of this. This is what they say
the situation is. I trust them. I'm going to go with their gut
on this. >> Okay. I don't want to spoil anything for you,
but but let's go ahead and just watch this video and then you
you can tell me if you think you would go back on the things
that he says in this >> Oh, sure. Yeah. I again I just
most of my things are like Hassan is not like a comically evil
person, right? >> Uh no, he believes that America is comically
evil. >> He believes the projection of American might is
comically evil and then you would be handing that military over
to >> I think essentially that he would be confronted with
facts that change the mind of even the most presidents. I do
not believe that Hassan is like a a more dumb or less apt decision
maker than Donald Trump. And Donald Trump has changed his mind
and Donald Trump's positions were far like I I think like almost
far more like his >> the question was not Donald Trump.
It >> he's doing well no it becomes Donald Trump from the
Twitter stuff but you might not have been watching like the argument
Destiny Pisco had was Trump versus uh Hassan. Just to be clear,
I think Trump is like horrible for people in America that are
not like, you know, that are not, you know, the What's the opposite
of heterodox? The homodox. He's not good for the homodoc, Mr.
Jessical. Not good at all. Not not good. Sorry. He's not good
for the heterodox in America. He's not good for people that aren't
that don't fall in, you know, aren't the straight white whatever
Christians. But but I still think America keeping its hedgeim
hedgemony is like better for the world than America losing its
hedgemony. And you were just saying that, oh, if you just sat
Hassan down and showed him the intelligence, he would look at
him and be like, oh, actually, it's really good that America
is the global hedgemon, and we actually need to continue projecting
force, and I'm actually going to address my
>> That that comes down, it's really easy. Do you think
America has acted in like the global interest for the past, you
know, four to six decades?
>> Okay. Do you believe that Hassan is against that idea
while having the same information and understanding that you
have or do you think he is missing? Do you think he's looked
at the same facts that you have and he's come to a completely
different conclusion that America is actually evil? >> Uh
I don't think he's I don't think he's I don't think he acknowledges
the information that that leads me to that decision that that
leads me to that position. Yeah. I don't think he just I think
he has uh he's aware of that information and don't he doesn't
believe they're facts. He believes that they're lies. They're
State Department lies. >> Or he believes propaganda. >> But
then I assume that when he has the ability to see that these
things are true, right? >> How's he going to see it? he
would be president of the United States. >> Okay. And what
does he see? >> I don't I don't know. So, I'm talking to
you about it. >> What are they going to show him? >> I
don't know. >> Do you think there's like a golden document
or something in a >> Do I think that there are like actual
realistic like facts of the matter for why the State Department
makes decisions that seem like uh sometimes comically >> So,
hold on. They're going to show him what military buildup around
Taiwan. >> Uh military buildup andor like actual Chinese
intelligence that is showing that they are going to actually
like genocide that place. Like they are going to kill everybody
there. They're not They're not letting those people out
to the Okay. You don't think so? >> No, I No, I'm not sure
that it exists that there's a document that US intelligence is
aware of that says here's our plan to murder everyone in Taiwan
the moment that America backs >> You don't think that there
would be something that they could produce that shows like what
China's plans are, like how scorched earth they plan to go in
Taiwan, like military plans to invade Taiwan. You don't think
anything like that would be something US intelligence would have?
>> Yeah. Military plans to invade Taiwan. If you showed
if you showed Hassan military van uh plans to invade Taiwan,
do you think Hassan would just say like, "Oh, this is obviously
like they they don't get to do that." >> I think he would
I think he would have it explained to him by somebody. Here's
the thing. This this is my base level thinking. I do not think
Hassan is a worse human being than Donald Trump. I don't think
there's evidence of that. And I do not think he's a worse ingesttor
of information than Donald Trump. I don't think there's evidence
of that. I believe he would have his mind changed in a similar
way to how Donald Trump has had his mind changed once he had
the facts available to him. and people who had spent decades
like researching this and understanding it, explaining things
to him in a very >> Those people would be the exact people
that he tells his entire audience that are lying and just producing
propaganda every day. Why would he suddenly trust them? And and
if he even if he did trust them, do you think he would go out
in front of all of those people who he convinced based on all
these people I told you were liars for all these years are now
telling me things and you know what, I just believe them. >> The
Epstein file is all lies. Okay? They made it they made it all
up. >> Okay? So I'm I'm saying that I think he is better
than Trump in these ways and I've watched Trump operate in this
way and make the correct decisions after being like explain after
having things explained to him. Trump isn't known for being consistent.
Trump is just known for being a guy that people love. Is Hassan
known for being consistent? >> I think I think people Yeah,
I think people think he's got a consistent worldview that he
can articulate and I think that that is true to a certain extent,
but I think it's just based in uh like actual Soviet propaganda.
>> listen. I'm not making a claim about which one's the
better person. In my heart of hearts, I believe Hassan is a a
communist because he thinks it's morally >> I think Yes.
Yes. Exactly. I think he believes that he is a communist because
he thinks that is the like empathetic and and altruistic way
to to live in the world. Right. >> Yes. And I think he
thinks what he thinks about American hedgemony uh because he
thinks that that's just and righteous. But >> I think he
thinks that American hedgemony used to enrich a small number
of people. He's probably not even that incorrect, right? That
American hedgeimonyy has been used to enrich a small number of
people at the expense of the broader globe, right? It's just
that probably in absence of that, we we both argue that actually
those people are even though they're like kind of getting they're
kind of getting raped, they'd be it'd be far worse if this hedgemony
didn't exist. Like this is >> the lesser of two evils.
Like if America was not a global hedgeiment, the world would
be worse. that that people are enriching themselves off of like
the global south in general, but it would be worse if America
was not like the global hedgemen. Like there would be war. There
would be like starvation. We could feed all of the people. Like
everything would be worse. Yeah. No, but there's I mean there's
more to that as well. I I don't think Hassan is is necessarily
super committed to democracy. Uh like if you were to say to him,
you know what, United States has a global hedgemon. Sure. Uh
maybe a byproduct of that is that they've made people like a
smaller number of people really wealthy. But how do they achieve
that? by promoting global trade. >> Am I crazy? I thought
the whole point of the the leftovers conversation was that actually
he felt like they would they would vote and he would respect
any dem democratic decision. >> He did say that. He did
say that with a smirk on his face. >> Okay. That with a
smirk on his face. >> Yeah, he did. >> Okay. So I'm
curious
and again >> I would say when we found this and this is
like an example of him sitting here with somebody who's super
far left. He's talking about how I don't know who this person
is a lot of his >> this person is boy boy from I did a
thing but I don't know what their views are. You that's just
something just to be clear. You you don't know who this person
is either. >> Oh I could have sworn he said he made a video
that was like positive about North Korea and a bunch of Brazilians
were like going nuts over it. That's why I was like oh if you
made a positive video about North Korea then I have I made assumptions
off of that. >> Uhhuh. Okay. Yeah. Uh, hold on. Either
way, I need to One second. I just need to You keep going. I'm
uh I need to reset this my >> I don't know. I've made my
argument. >> Yeah. I don't I don't think your argument
is like horrible, >> but I don't think um >> I just
think it's closer. I don't I don't think it's that serious of
a question, but you know, but it's just it's closer than I think
you're you're like making it out like it's really obvious uh
to choose Trump. I I think there's a lot of danger in >> I
think I think given um the exact like safeguards in place in
America right now, it's very easy to choose Trump or sorry Hassan
over Trump. Like I think I think basically the safeguards of
the parties as they exist right now, you were to have an election
right now where you could pick one of the two with the existing
parties. Obviously the Republican party is built to enable this
like fascist takeover of America, right? They've been weeded
out. Every single person who's a dissenting voice has been weeded
out entirely. The Democrats basically can't find unity because
they have so many dissenting voices, right?
>> We're kind of talking about a reality where Hassan has
enough support to become the president. >> Sure. But the
entire purpose of the conversation in general is to talk about
who the DNC could find an ally in now today, right? And so changing
the dynamics of the party so significantly that Trump could be
president wouldn't make sense. It like defeats the purpose of
asking the hypothetical in the first place. It is saying like
basically you shouldn't be think Hassan is so bad that we can't
talk to him or we can't talk to people around him. That's like
silly, right? And we shouldn't think that it's better to talk
to people around Charlie Kirk. Sorry, it's it wouldn't be better
to like have Charlie Kirk as an ally than it would be Hassan.
Hassan overlaps on our values way more than Charlie >> But
Trump didn't enter office January whatever 2016 with the ability
to do what he's done to the party. It was after a decade of building
a cult of personality and uh and assembling like you know political
power that consolidating his power that way. >> Sure. And
technically Hassan could do that, but I would say the threat
of Trump having like being 50% down that road, it's like, do
you want your TNT with like the full fuse or would you like the
TNT with like a 30% of the fuse left? And what Hassan wants to
do with that, I think, is I think it's close. I think it's like
pretty close is even more nefarious than what Trump. If you take
the worst I think if you take the worst quotes from Hassan, >> the
worst quotes from Hassan and put them against um like the broad
total of Trump's actions. But why don't we just take like Trump's
worst quotes then? Right? Trump wants to literally like genocide
anybody who's like a terrorist and their families, right? He
just wants to kill all of them, right? Should we just take all
of his worst quotes, get like immediately deport all illegal
immigrants? Like uh literally get rid of them all like and actually
just anybody who's coming over the border illegally, right? We
could go to like the absolute worst quotes of him and he sure
looks evil at that point. Oh yeah, like uh Putin, everybody's
bullying Putin. We need to get Putin back like in the in the
in the seat there in the saddle there, right? Like dude, if you
want to just take the worst statements people have made and say
that's like what they would do. I don't know. It seems kind of
I you kind of have to take the broad totality of who somebody
is. And I just >> okay, which which of the two do you think
are is more ideologically devoted? >> Uh depends on what
you say the ideology is. I don't think Trump has a political
ideology. Ideology
is himself, right? >> Yes. Exactly. So when he says something
that he just thinks people thinks uh people will think sounds
good. When he just says something that he knows people will be
like, "Ooh, that hit me in the bones. It made me shiver a little
bit." >> You know, I don't think you can compare >> Hassan
is holy. Never mind. Just watch the video. I'm out. Why can't
I get through a sentence? >> Never mind. >> Watch
the video. >> Talk to you later. Bye. >> But there
wouldn't look islands just militarize themselves, you know. Okay,
eventually. So, this document from the US Department of Defense,
this document is called the national >> I was just going
to say if Hassan's ideologically motivated, why does he have
all the capital is in his background? Why is he like uh why does
he have like a $900 shirt on? >> Defense strategy of the
United States of America, which also includes the nuclear posture
review and missile. >> Isn't that what all communists do?
They lar doing it for the people and then gather all the resources
and then use it for themselves. Maybe was it a LAR or is it ideology?
>> It's a basically a report. >> This is basically
one thing you have to come down on. I I I think it's really disingenuous
to argue both sides of it >> that they release every four
years that gives us >> an understanding of what the US
>> Oh yeah, we could pull Kingler in. Kingler was waiting
to come in. Kingler 92, welcome to the stream. How's it
>> What they care about
>> like like China and who would have >> What's up,
Kingler? How's it going? >> Good. How you guys doing? Um,
>> pretty good. >> First thing I I I found a lot
of uh value in exploring this uh hypothetical personally. Um,
it really I feel like um I'm I'm more conscious of my potential
to slip into
Assan derangement
um syndrome. Uh I tried to be. I'm not not that I'm always successful.
Um, but I feel like I'm not mindful of my Trump derangement syndrome
at all. Like I never in a million years would have ever uh explored
a hypothetical
might be the better option. Do you think that there's value in
that at all? >> Okay, cool. >> Thank god Pisco came
up with this hypothetical. I guess W Pisco. Well, yeah, it's
a it is an interesting hypothetical and I think uh people should
be mindful mindful of uh of uh not just accepting their their
biases even accidentally. Um do you first thing I want to ask
do you think it's possible
for a person who is maybe more is a is a is a good person maybe
a better person than Trump but still have a worse outcome for
America long term? better person, worse outcome. I mean, I almost
want to say instinctually I want to say no because I think basically
any president could be informed by people into like actually
running the country well and I think anybody who is a good enough
person will be able to look at these facts presented to them
by these people who have done their this job their entire lives.
I don't think being the president is actually that difficult.
I think it is largely a moral like you are a moral center for
the country, right? So I think that is most of the job. So no,
I think most people who are better people than Trump would do
a better job running the country. >> But so you don't think
a person's individual values matters at all? It's just whether
they're what >> I think they matter at all. But I think
a lot of it comes down to like realities. So places where individual
values matter is like Trump, you know, personally enriching himself
at the cost or at the expense of the country, right? I don't
think I'd have to worry about Hassan doing that in the same way.
But at the same time, uh I'm trying to think of like it's probably
around the military where you would think that where you think
like individual values could maybe clash or something and make
them worse. But I I think realistically Trump or sorry Hassan
would end up making the correct decisions in much the same way
we've seen Trump make the correct decisions with regards to like
Ukraine for example. >> Trump has a has a vested interest
in
control. Um he he likes uh you know if we're if we're mind readading
um he likes being like the boss, right? He he views himself as
like a as a mafioso kind of guy and I think all things would
serve into maintaining that that
um perception and m maintaining that power and therefore he has
an invested interest
um in making sure America remains the the global you know the
the the guys on the wheel um and I I don't think Hassan has that
same >> why do you think he why do you think he has that
interest? because he likes
the top dog. >> What part of his rhetoric makes you think
that that's something he cares
>> Yes. What part of any of his rhetoric around NATO makes
you think that's what he thinks? Did you just forget everything
he's ever said about NATO? >> No, I I just didn't expect
to have to justify that that um that claim. Uh so now I'm trying
to think of
that. >> Uh my sorry, somebody asked why around NATO. Um
I my belief would be that actually like a strong and persistent
NATO is critical to keeping the US the global hedgeimon. Would
you disagree with that? >> Okay. So I I believe a lot of
his around NATO shows like how his thoughts what his thoughts
were. >> Right. I think he started to change those over
time because he's been obviously made privy to information that
made him go oh wait that would actually be stupid to like defund
NATO or something. But that's what he was that that's what he
wanted to do, right? >> So you don't think that Trump has
an interest in maint in making sure America stays the top dog?
>> No, I don't think so. I don't think he particularly
cares. I don't think he particularly cares about America being
like the global hedgeimon
um >> in terms of influence. He wants it to be the global
he wants them to control the the planet via the military. He
wants to be a strong man. He has no interest in soft power. This
is the argument everybody has made and everybody's understood
for 10 years now that Trump has no care or concern for soft power
at all. And suddenly I'm having people coming in here and like
explain to me how actually Trump's really concerned about America's
position as the global hedgeiment. Do you think America does
that through the military or do you think they do that through
diplomacy? It's both, but >> they do it. >> Both
are critical. >> I I'm trying to understand the distinction
between he he wants to be top dog talk. I don't think he cares
whether it's through he it seems like he doesn't like NATO cuz
everyone else is paying less than America does and he feels like
a chump. I just I literally have to >> I literally have
to ask was the was not one of the primary criticisms of Trump
going into this election was that Trump was going to threaten
America's place as the global hedgeman that he was like actually
it was actually concerning that he was like in the pocket of
Russia that's how badly he was with America's global authority
has he not made decision were the global tariffs not literally
that level of decision where it's like oh this guy might just
be a Russian stoouchge he's actually with America in like every
possible way he
>> okay all right so we have got a whole bunch of evidence
of Trump doing this in reality of with America's place as a global
hedgeiment in reality, but we've gone, you know what, I think
Hassan would get in there and he he'd just go, you know what,
my Twitch politics career is maybe equipped to override this
four-star general. You we're pulling the whole military back.
>> Yeah. But the the difference is that he he all of those
things he trying to do. He he backs off on because it does threaten
that, right? Like he he he wants to do the tariffs. He wants
to have like a military parade to be the strong guy, but when
things aren't going his way, he's like, "Oh, okay. This so this
isn't working. I'm I'm gonna >> Why do you think won't
back off or whatever it is?" Because that's what that's his ultimate
goal. That's what he wants. He He wants to to level the playing
field. He doesn't think that America should be the top dog. >> Okay.
So where Trump has a vested interest in maintaining >> We've
seen all of this evidence that presidents go in with goals and
then they totally back off of those goals because they are either
given information that shows them that those goals are dumb or
detrimental or they realize those goals are infeasible. And you're
arguing that Hassan will be the one of the singular presidents
who goes and says actually everybody else way more than Trump.
Trump's shown way more propensity for doing that, right? He's
shown actual propensity for wanting to do that. But you think
you think will come in and be way stronger than than Trump and
like just be like, "Yeah, all these people, all of these advisers,
they all suck." >> These are these are two outliers, right?
Have we ever had a fascist or a >> We don't have any evidence
of what Trump would have any evidence of what Hassan would do
as president at all. We have evidence with regards to Trump.
We don't have evidence with regards to Hassan. >> Okay.
What's the point of of
where we're exploring a hypothetical >> that we're taking
Hassan's like strongest statements that he's made as a Twitch
streamer, as an entertainer, and pretending that that's like
what he would do as president? >> Well, if he's going to
if if the hypothetical is he's going to abandon all of his principles
and all of his beliefs, then okay, then then I guess >> is
that the president of the United States operates within certain
bounds and that they have more information than other people.
I believe a lot of Hassan's positions with regards to being anti-American
hedgemony have to do with him being uninformed, him not understanding
what the realities are. That broadly he is probably a good person
who generally like wants good things for most people. That when
confronted situation, he will actually back down and say, you
know what, I actually can see now that what I thought was probably
wrong. >> Okay, I guess >> I think you could just
ask us on this, right? You can say, hey, let's say you get in
and you realize that like actually you get information. you you
have all the facts and actually America's been a pretty responsible
actor on the global stage given the information they had. Right.
You just >> argument is >> your your argument is
is we can't take him at his word. He's going to change completely
when he becomes president. I I guess >> my
disagree that he is a Twitch entertainer. If we took Destiny
at his word, he kids. >> What does that have to do with
anything? >> I'm saying it would be to take a joke or something
where they're speaking even even in terms of like things they've
argued for randomly like on stream. It would be crazy to take
this entertainer who is not actually like a like a wonk of any
kind and say this is what they're going to do automatically if
they get into office because we've watched it happen with Trump
and he has not been able to do that. >> He he tried but
he got he got pushed back and he he he threatens his his power
which he doesn't want. Hassan has different values where he he
might not care. We like you said we we don't know but I mean
both acknowledge >> that I think Trump is far more of a
psychopath far more of a hateful person far more of a bad person
in general. I think Hassan actually has some moral character
to him a little bit. Okay. I think he is broadly somebody who
would want good things for most people. >> I don't disagree
with that. I'm I'm sure he does. But he might just believe that
the good things for most people is that America is not
>> smasher. Hold on. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up
for two seconds. Razel smasher. You're clearly a okay not a wonk
of any kind. He's the number one left-leaning political streamer.
You and Asmin Gold is the number one right-leaning streamer.
Is Asminold not a [__] who knows nothing about policy?
Holy, you're lost.
yourself, you loser. Hermud, don't come back. Go be a loser somewhere
else. Holy [__] That person needs to feel embarrassed.
Feel embarrassed, bro. Sorry. Go ahead, Kingler. My bad. I cut
you off. Um,
>> doesn't the number one entertainer in politics mean
that they know stuff about like a lot about politics. They know
about how policy and what's feasible? No, obviously not. Holy
[__] Sorry. Go >> I just don't I don't really
know how to you just don't want you just don't take Hassan at
his word, I guess. And I don't really know how to >> I
would need to look for his word in multiple places because I
think a lot of the other things Hassan said that have to do with
his word have probably been being pro-democracy, right? being
pro like will of the people, being pro like uh universal healthcare,
being pro a bunch of things I would like. So I'd have to look
at the totality of his opinions. I'd need a much better idea
of who he is as a political actor to say that he would do these
things. I don't know how serious this is, right? And I do believe
that he thinks China is like not the morally bad actor in the
South China Sea. I believe he's moronic
in that way, right? I believe when he's shown the timeline and
shown all the information that he will go, "Oh, I guess yeah,
we probably do have to help these people." Yeah, they're they're
with the Philippines. God damn, this is actually reallyed up,
right? When he's shown the actual video of it, when he's shown
that it's really happening when it's not propaganda, that's that's
what I believe it will be, right? I I think he will be able to
make that decision. >> But but >> and I know, sorry,
just real quick, I know the argument against this is like, oh,
but what if he like argues that these people lie all the Yeah,
it's basically the deep state. It's like the equivalent of the
deep state. If if Trump can make that decision, I think basically
anybody can make that decision. Th >> this video that that
would be shown to him is stuff that's happening now or the results
of something he's already ordered and is being carried out and
it's the ramifications of >> because what what what are
what is he being shown in this hypothetical that that changes
his mind? >> Okay, China is mobilizing towards Taiwan,
right? And he goes, "China is like actually the moral authority
in the South China Sea." And they go and they do like the whole
Supreme pitch like look, they're building these ATLs. They've
actually been bullying the [__] out of the Philippines.
They are actually creating all the conflict here. We just want
to contain them because here's what they're doing to build up
their nuclear triad. And once they have this, they've shown that
once they have an effective nuclear triad, here's Chinese doctrine.
Effective nuclear triad leads to us invading Taiwan because the
US can no longer engage with us. This is how it is. And to keep
the world safe, to keep like our supply of chips safe, to keep
the world safe, here's what we have to do, right?
do I Okay. I don't know how I I'm not a you know a political
expert in terms of like communists and and socialists or or whatever
the Trump is. But uh let's say Hassan finds himself in a situation
where
um the the value of the dollar is plummeting, the US dollar is
plummeting. Um, and people are selling off the Treasury bonds
and Trump backs off because obviously he's threatening his position
uh in the world uh as the president as whatever. Do you think
Hassan would value that in the same way and he would he would
back off in that particular circumstance? >> Yeah, I believe
that people are like here's what's going to happen. I believe
you get the smartest people in the world there showing you the
externalities of your decision and you back off. Yes, I believe
that if Trump would back off from his ego in that situation,
then I believe Hassan would also back off in that exact situation.
>> What's the value of Hassan over Trump if at the end
of the day they're just going to listen to whoever hands them
the piece of paper with the secret >> Because Hassan got
because Trump assigned conservatives to the Supreme Court, you
[__]
Trump has ruined your Trump is trying to plunge your country
into fascism, right? Keep the same advisers there, but he wants
it to be fascist, right? He wants it to be around him. He wants
a third term. Couldn't Hassan just add a bunch of super super
far-lefty judges and and do the same exact damage? >> He
could. Wouldn't super far far lefty judges be way more in line
with your >> Uh, I don't know. Would what if I don't know
what communist judges would would rule on? I I don't I don't
really have >> Are there communist judges? Are there a
lot of communist Supreme Court judges? >> I really don't
know. I don't really have the expertise to to say for sure. I'm
trying to explore the hypothetical with you and you seem really
triggered >> because I've explained to you that you do
Hold on. Do you think Trump is good? Do you think Trump given
outside of his decisions where experts overrule him, you think
Trump's been good? >> You don't think Assam would be better
on >> On abortion? Yeah, for sure. >> Okay. On civil
rights?
>> actually, here, give me the give me the situation where
you think Trump would be better outside of places where you just
like social issues essentially, not places you just defer to
like economic or military authority. Give me the place where
you think Trump's better than Hassan. Well, it feels like what
this fundamentally comes down to is >> I didn't Hold on.
Can you give me the place where you like Trump better than Hassan
on issues where an expert wouldn't overrule you. Like like I'm
I'm talking about social issues like things where you think it's
basically like you understand your morality. You have a good
handle on this, right? >> I don't I I'm not really concerned
about social issues when it comes to I'm more concerned about
America's place when it >> Are you concerned about social
issues when it comes to Trump? >> Uh yeah, absolutely.
>> Okay. So, I'm trying to help you make this like trade-off,
help you understand this trade-off. So, I'm asking you, obviously,
you're saying if if Hassan will if they'll both just defer, you
asked me if they both just defer to experts in those fields,
then what's the difference? And then I responded with what the
differences. Can you admit that that was a stupid like hypothetical
to go down? Like that was obviously wrong. Obviously, Hassan
would be better if they both defer to experts in any expert >> Uh,
when it comes to social issues, Oh, I see what you're saying.
Um, I mean, yeah, but I I don't I was asking about your view.
I don't believe that they would defer to whatever expert is in
the room across the board for every single issue. I was just
trying to >> my view. You said if they if all else is equal,
if they'll both defer to experts in that situation, then what's
the difference? You said they would be >> I said, no, obviously
they wouldn't be equal. There would be like these social issues.
There's no
there's no expert on gay marriage, right? >> That's what
I was asking. If all things being equal, what what would be the
difference? and and you said social issues and and I would I
agree Hassan will be better on social issues. That's just not
really my concern when it comes to electing Hassan. >> Okay.
But the the issue is the trade-off between the two. We've we've
equalized the other issues and then you said what would the difference
be? I'm saying social issues. What's confusing? Obviously Hassan
would be better than >> I'm not I'm not confused. Yeah.
On social issues, Hassan would be better. >> You already
you already took the other things and said they would be equal
there, right? They'll both defer to experts on those things.
No, I >> what can you ask? Okay, so now so now we will
just get to the question I actually asked you which was point
to the issue where Trump is better than Hassan outside of like
military or like economic issues where you would defer to like
an expert in your cabinet. >> I I don't I don't agree that
I don't I'm not taking the bullet that Hassan would across the
board defer to experts, >> or military people. >> I'm
saying you I'm doing the opposite. I'm trying to see why you
said to me that if they both defer experts, what would the difference
be? I'm doing I'm >> I was trying to
then you say I don't think that would be my biggest problem with
Hassan would be social issues. So I'm saying what other issues
would there be in that hypothetical? Are you just saying that
that obviously if they both defer to experts, you would take
Assan every day of the week, right? They if they defer to military
experts, you take Assan automatically. If they defer to economic
experts, you take Assan
>> Okay, perfect. >> There are a lot of situations
where I would take HSN automatically. Um, that's what I think
is super interesting about exploring the hypothetical. Um, in
terms of exploring my own personal beliefs and and challenging
the idea of of Trump derangement syndrome. Um, that's what I
think is fun about exploring it. You don't seem like you're having
much fun, >> I I think it's really weird to explore this
because I've already explored this. I've made these arguments
that I didn't think January 6 was that bad. I've gone through
all of this already, but I think uh a lot of people haven't and
now they're like they're suddenly making the most arguments I've
ever heard in my life is like very weird, right? Like would you
not say that January 6 was like an actual terrorist attack on
America's soul? >> Yes, of course. >> And Donald
Trump like actually architected and and enacted that. >> Okay.
What has Hassan done that is anywhere near that that makes you
think that Donald Trump is a better leader for America than Hassan?
I mean, obviously Hassan is not president, but the idea would
be that at least with Trump, uh, the the attack is within America
and America's we have a chance of keeping America standing in
the in the greater world. But with Hassan, his goal is the exact
opposite if we were to take him at his at his word. So where
January 6 is a tragedy of American history, it's the worst thing
to happen, you know, at the Capitol ever, there there are there
are scenarios or hypotheticals you can explore with Hassan as
president where you can have a
a terrorist situation that threatens the entire world order,
which would be worse long term. >> I'm back.
Okay, you feeling you had a Snickers. You feeling good now? >> Yeah,
there's a there's a better argument for this. Like yes, what
Donald Trump did, what January 6 was was an attack on the American
soul, but like in one way and for the end of Donald Trump's vanity.
Donald Trump did January 6 because Donald Trump wants to wants
the power. I think that's different from like when you compare,
let's compare the worst things Hassan has said to Donald Trump,
the worst like Trump has worse things. Yeah, that's true. The
difference is that Hassan says these things from an articulable
ideological center. He's got an entire view of the world that
he can articulate to you that's built on um like basically an
understanding of of information that you and I think is false.
>> That's not that that the actions he takes with regards
to his consumerism fly in the face of that ideology ideology
completely. >> Yeah. Well, then you're just arguing that
he doesn't actually believe uh he doesn't actually believe that
for example like >> Do you think there's more evidence
that >> Sorry. Sorry. Go ahead. >> No, no, no. No.
I spoke a bunch there. Do you do you believe there's more evidence
that he does believe or doesn't believe in that ideology given
his actions? Can we get >> Yeah, I think you're right.
I think I think there's more Well, yeah, I think there's more
evidence that at least when when offered the ability to live
a comfortable life, uh he he'll assue Yeah. Or he's able to double
think himself into thinking like actually everybody would be
able to live this way under my system. >> Yeah. Which is
Yeah. I don't know. I I personally think he's a guy who like
has an aesthetic and he like has done a little bit of reading
to like argue within that aesthetic, but honestly, he just probably
pretty quickly realized he's in over his head completely. Um,
I don't think he has the same level of like Trump where Trump's
been like a billionaire, right? And Trump thinks he's like the
generator of his success. I don't think Hassan's like quite to
that level of of narcissism. He's pretty close. He's pretty up
there, but I just I don't think he could um I just I don't see
it. It's it's honestly very much the similar argument where people
are like, "Oh, if Nick Fentes was president, you don't think
he'd genocide all these people?" No, he's like a theater kid
from Chicago. I don't think he's got it in his bones. I don't
think he could do it. Right. It's very similar to that argument,
right?
>> Like they're entertainers. >> I think he's I think
he's got that dog in him. Was an artist. Not even good enough
to be an artist. He was a bad >> He was an artist who went
to war for like a for did all of World War I. He wased up. Everybody
was up. >> Yeah. Yeah, but Fentes lives in Shyra.
>> What do you think about the the argument that um Trump
is a you said that Hassan is a but Trump fills his cabinets with
people who at least have some kind of uh America American best
interest and Hassan would fill his cabinet with >> Telsey
Gabbard is the director of national intelligence. You you have
to just give me better arguments than that. I'm sorry. That is
like the possibly the worst argument you've made on in the entirety
of time you've been on this stream. Yeah, Trump's Trump's cabinet
is is outright sedicious. >> Okay, fair. >> And incompetent.
>> Brutally incompetent. Like I think Pete Hexith probably
loves America. He just doesn't understand how to love a He's
literally just like he's incompetent. Too incompetent to do that
job. >> He can't stop He loves America. He just can't stop
running into her with the kitchen knife. Like he can't just,
you know, turning the corner. >> Rubio's a good guy. >> Yeah,
he's not so bad. Who would have picked for his cabinet? I don't
know. Probably people like AOC to be honest with you. Probably
like a lot of young people. a lot of young people with very far-left
beliefs. >> I have a hard I just have a hard time buying
that Hassan is going to have to come out and be like, "Okay,
guys, you know what? The CIA told me that China's actually bad
and uh you know, they're >> Porter Beller's mad at you,
Kenny. You can read his response. I think probably the um this
was the thing I said last night is like the worst case scenario
of Hassan is he pulls back global uh like American military presence
across the globe for four years and we have like disastrous outcomes
from that that you know he has to deal with. But I think um I
think Trump broadly like wanted to do that and specified that
he kind of wanted to move in that direction where like he wanted
to pull back almost all American power projection. He didn't
want to be a part of that, right? And something happened where
he went, "Oh, actually I was wrong on everything." And I feel
like at some point, well, his actions said that, right? Where
he basically left everything as it was. >> Yeah. But Trump
gets to sort of like promote people in the moment and demote
people depending on just kind of how he's feeling. You know what?
He's a very smart guy and he told me that, you know, he's able
to kind of do that. I don't know. I I the hardest thing for me
to swallow is that Hassan would ever come out and be like, "Guys,
the CIA was right about some stuff. I can't tell you or show
you, but that's a tough pill to swallow, especially >> I
think you don't even have to say they were right about stuff.
I think you'd say the situation in the ground is like this is
our best decision." You know, you don't like no president comes
out and justifies with like all of the information. It would
just be yeah, I have this is the best decision we can >> Here's
the real question. Who do you trust more? Maybe this is a better
act, actually a quicker way to get to the answer to this question.
Who do you trust more with your nine-year-old little cousin girl,
Donald Trump? Do you leave her for a day at Donald Trump's house
or do you leave her for a day at Hassan's house? >> That's
not hard at all. That's Hassan every day of the week. >> Yeah,
I think so. >> After those Epstein letters, I think Trump
kids unironically. I think I I think he I think I don't know
if Epste did like a I don't even know if I believe Epste did
a broad like
jacketing like I'm going to make you a 17-year-old or whatever.
But I think I think Trump and Clinton and Epste got up to some
really crazy [__] together. >> Yeah, Trump
saw the strawberries in the bowl and he's like can I have a >> I
love strawberries. >> Crazy. Is that a Eyes Wide Shut >> No,
I've never seen that movie. >> Okay. Neither have I. I
just couldn't >> Is that a thing in Eyes Eyes Wide Shut
they refer to children as strawberries? No, I just I thought
it was like some weird cult thing. Some weird um like >> succulent
hot dogs. >> Something like that. Yeah. Broadly, I just
I again I'm just going to keep hammering that like I think Hassan
is mostly like not a horrible human being that would like and
I I think Trump is like a I think Trump if he could like bankrupt
America to know that he would live like as a as like a god emperor
over the world. I think he would do that in a second. I actually
don't know if his son would do that. I think his son like broadly
has like other people around him that are good. He has like broadly
like a like a good morality to him. I think he wants to make
the right decisions. I think he that's like kind of overroought
by his narcissism at times, but it's pretty transparent when
that's what's happening. I don't know. I I just don't I but I
don't feel that same same way about Trump. I think Trump is like
actually like a >> you know what bad person. >> Yeah.
I I guess like Assan did come out and say Putin is bad at least
on the EVA even though to this day he has not eaten crow on his
Ukraine commentary pre-invasion like leading up to the invasion
to this day like he'll say yeah you know I was actually right
I said it would be stupid for Putin to do this and and it was
stupid for him to do that. >> No you said the state the
state
admit he's wrong and so maybe if he had to come out and make
a statement maybe that would be hard for him. Um cuz it was it
was like that's all he can admit. Okay. The State Department
gave good intelligence to the public. That's like his line. >> Uh
anyway, listen, I'm not going to make you sit through an hour
of this video. Basically, he says that the reason that the United
States has such a presence and uh Japan, I'll save you an hour.
Japan, South Korea, the Philippines, um, and Taiwan is because
>> we just want to wave our around and, and we actually
intimidate these countries into forcing them into letting us
have our military be there, uh, with with economic, you know,
basically economic consequences and by force. >> Yeah,
obviously that is not true. I think I think a lot of those some
of those countries might become less scared, but like I think
Japan is probably the people who are like Taiwan's obviously
scared because they would be getting invaded, but I think Japan's
pretty scared that like if China gained like um some level of
multipolarity in the world with the United States and could start
bullying them that like suddenly suddenly China's like, "Hey,
guess what? we're tariffing you 10% and we're not you can't tariff
us back and if you don't let us do that then we're actually just
going to make sure that shipping containers can't reach you right
like like there's nothing preventing that from happening and
America is the defender of like the waterways and the defender
of like global currency right global global commerce is what
I meant and I don't think I don't think Japan or any of those
rich Japan or South Korea >> have any faith that China
would keep that up would keep that like economic freedom up I
think China would start like basically trying to cut deals or
trying to bully people immediately economically kind of in the
way the US is with Trump a little bit with the tariffs and [__]
So >> yeah, of course. But yeah, one of the things that
they march out as evidence for why this is the case, by the way,
that the US just strongarms these countries into letting us project
our military from uh from their territories is that like the
uh like basically, you know, the the maritime charters of these
countries, not the maritime charters, but basically like the
the defense sort of annual defense like statements or goals or
whatever in their like defense charters, they will have word
for word uh the exact same line about like uh defending um against
Chinese expansionism in the seas And it's like word for word,
every single word word for word. They'll say, "This is evidence
that it's all ghostwritten by the State Department or something
like that." It's
>> I'm I'm so sorry, Supreme. I got I I'm I got to hop
off. Um >> How dare you? Go ahead. >> Really really
quick, Jay Talk. I was I was genuinely asking that the message
that I got timed out for. I don't know if you thought I was being
um koi or something. I I genuinely didn't know whether he he
had said that or not. Um so I I hope you >> Well, I don't
know. It was it was literally just wildly outside of like >> is
Hassan is Hassan's position it was inevitable or also justified.
Um >> yeah I don't know either. I I literally don't know
either. >> I don't know if that was the thing I timed you
out for if it was one of the previous ones. >> Okay. Um
I tried to be good faith. I don't claim to be an expert. Um I
I would much rather listen >> I'll time you out. I'll time
you out. >> Okay. All right. You guys have a good night
stream. >> See you. Bye. >> So yeah, you can skip
this video now if you want. He just it's just exactly all the
[__] I just said. Maybe some more. Maybe there's
more. >> Yeah, I think he will make excuses, anti-state
department, anti- US diplomacy or anti- US foreign policy excuses
like all of the time. >> This is where this like stops
being an interesting exercise to me because like this is so far
removed from we have no idea how the you know we only know how
he operates as an influencer and uh like we haven't seen him
how he reacts to political pressure ever. I don't know. Like
it's just it's like saying who would win in a fight like a pissed-off
fire ants or like 100,000 king penguins or whatever emperor penguins.
It's kind of like okay this is not really >> probably 100,000
penguins versus 10,000 ants. I feel like it would be the the
>> Hold on, man. Those crazy Amazonian fire ants could
you up man. >> Yeah, but there's 100,000 penguins. >> Yeah,
but penguins are stupid and they're not really aggressive. They
kind of just like take it for a little while. Even if one of
them was like getting eaten alive next to another penguin, are
penguins known for defending each other or do they just like
jump in the water? >> They only have like tough skin right
>> They got like thick fur, but think about that, man.
Maybe their skin's like real sensitive under that fur. I mean,
it's basically padded. It's like they're wearing they're they're
pillows. They're wearing a pillow all the time. >> But
like penguins like slide on ice. Think going to do anything?
>> There's only one way to find out. You know, we need
to have a serious discussion about this. What does Pisco think
about this actually? >> Well, we could figure that out
at some point. He's in the Discord. He'd always join up. Oh,
why is this guy This guy came in and said he's banned from my
Discord, so I can't join. Okay. Uh,
>> what is he banned for? Based Perry. I don't know who
that is. He's banned from my Discord, so he can't join. Let's
see here. Hands. >> What an idiot. >> Based Perry.
Who is this guy? Let's see what he got banned for. What do you
think he got banned for, guys? Head out. Give me a second. Based
Perry. Oh. Oh, I'm looking in the wrong place. Hold on. What
did this guy get? Oh, he's not banned. He just made his account,
didn't he? Or is he banned? Hold on. Oh, yeah. He literally was
spamming Juice Docker a bunch in the Discord and then he's like,
"Why am I banned? >> I called it. >> I'm banned.
Why am I banned?" Uh, you're annoying. Probably. I'm I'm guessing.
I'm just guessing. I'm just throwing it out there. It seems probable.
Hold on. Let's pull up. Maybe Maybe he's critiqued some of my
streams on his stream. Doing my own research. We have sound here.
What's going on? We not have sound. Dude, you got to work on
your What's the bit rate going on here?
>> Feels bad. He's watching Destiny. Big Destiny fan. >> Can
they get away with that though? No. But I don't They're not trying
to like >> This guy's very upset. It might be content to
unt.
But they're not trying to win it. They're just trying to drag
this out as much as possible. Like it wouldn't surprise me if
they got a bunch of vowed
on these upcoming motions. If they did that they would like dismiss
the case. >> Like I have no faith in them actually handing
over like what we've asked for in Discovery. I don't think >> silently
listening to Destiny. I wonder why he doesn't like me. I ban
this guy. Hop in the Discord, bro. Get in here. We'll pull you
in right now. Banning the only black guy in this community. No.
Lots of black guys in this community. Kenny's in the call right
now. The are you talking about? Kenny's not black.
>> Is B? Yeah, that was Bass Perry's channel. We'll pull
him in here. Maybe he will be the first EG to come in and and
actually cook. Yeah, I don't know. I was saying Supreme. I don't
know if you're in here or not, but um that was probably my biggest
uh concern with Hassan if you were to like make him president.
The original question was supposed to be about like ally for
the DNC, right? But if you make a song on president, probably
pulling back the military has uh pretty sketch effects on things.
So, and the link, it's
I'm sure you can handle putting that into your browser. Exclamation
boy discord in the chat, too. Maybe pulling back the military
could have, you know, maybe the maybe that's like the one thing
Trump has been missing. It could cause uh like some of our allies
to step up in ways that they haven't been or whatever and fill
some of the gaps. But in in Southeast Asia that just can't just
they just don't have it. They don't have the ability, the capability.
Like a lot of the places where we project our our military are
not very stable. Thailand is a good example. Um you know the
Philippines is not going to be able to project obviously like
enough military might to supplant what the US is currently doing
there. Yeah. South Korea has you know a sort of like border war
that it's still engaged in somewhat that it has to raise readiness
for. Japan could maybe do it. Give him 10 20 years. They're certainly
expanding. I just unbanned this guy. >> Did you banavate
on something? Base Perry guy. You're unbanned. Your main account's
unbanned. >> You bade
a different >> Well, no, no, no, no. But like his uh he's
got a different account in here that is not banned, but you can't
be on that account. You got to leave on that account. Joining
your main account, you're age gated out on this other one. Oh,
unless also you have a 10-minute There's like a 10-minute timer
when they first join voice, right? Who is this guy? Why are we
stopping the content for him? Who cares? >> Uh he's like
super mad. I love when people are super like uh like seething.